okay spring statement today the
government is going to slash your
benefits slash your spending raise your
taxes all the while doing nothing about
the growing wealth of the richest listen
as the richest get richer and richer and
richer and richer they are squeezing
everybody else out of the economy that
means you don't have any wealth your
family doesn't have any wealth the
middle class and the working class have
nothing left to spend and the government
becomes bankrupted as well the
government is rowing a boat with a
massive hole in the bottom and wealth is
Flowing out away from ordinary families
towards the richest people in the
country and the only solution the
government has is to tell you guys to
row harder listen until we get our
wealth back until you get our wealth
back this will not get better the only
way to solve this situation is to
rebalance the tax system so that the
richest pay their fair share and
Ordinary People pay less tax wealth not
work send it to Rachel Reeves